[Music]
celebrating the fourth of july weekend
is taking on a new meaning for one
family
they recently discovered a diary of
sorts from the husband of betsy ross
john claypool
as jerika duncan explains finding that
diary
led them to finding family they didn't
even know existed
they're perfect strangers united by
history that goes back more than 200
years
it's just so amazing last month at the
museum of the american revolution in
philadelphia
eileen edge so i'm actually not even 100
sure how we i don't really know
yeah we're going to have to have
somebody explain the connections
met her cousin steve balderston for the
first time
they're both descendants of betsy ross
so betsy ross was your
great great great great grandmother
yes do you recall the first time you
learned about
betsy ross i it's quite honestly i was
told
probably before i could even understand
it betsy ross was steve balderston's
great great great grandmother
in 2019 that side of the family came
across a sea chest from the american
revolution
engraved on the top the name john
claypool
betsy ross's third husband you started
off really with this
chest what was that like that was pretty
exciting
originally been in my house in the
family house
and so i made a couple calls
and my cousin richard balderston and
claudia
said that it would be great to be
donated to the museum
one year later nearly 3 000 miles away
in redmond washington eileen and her
husband david
were going through her mother's
belongings wrapped up in a piece of
paper that said to be preserved with
great care
which we did laugh yeah that's in the
garage
in an old seared shoe box oh wow this
could have easily been thrown out
easily in the paper it said diary of
john claypool
that diary describes the experiences of
claypool as a prisoner of war
and historians believe the sea chest
could have been with him
before he was captured by the british mr
joseph ashburn
i beg leave to inform you that he was
brought to this prison in a short time
after me
here claypool writes about his friend
joseph ashburn
betsy ross's second husband he died in
the night
of the third of march after an illness
of about 10 days
which he bore with a amazing fortitude
one year later ross and claypool married
what is it like to hold that it's
completely mind blowing
this is probably only the third or
fourth time i've held it since we found
it
because we just didn't want to disrupt
debt we wanted to make sure it stayed in
great shape
eileen reached out to the revolution
museum in philadelphia which has only
been around since 2017.
she was put in contact with chief
historian philip mead
the same man who helped her cousin a
year earlier
well he said you know we have the john
claypool chess and he said i know that
side of the family i would love to
connect you and i was like that's so
amazing we would love to be connected
with them
how exciting is this to to get a find
like this and to reconnect families
together
it's one of the events of a lifetime we
had just
recently acquired this sea chest
that belonged to john claypool it was
just too good to be true
how valuable is a diary like this
it's invaluable to scholarship to the
public
it's our closest approximation of
actually meeting john claypool or betsy
ross they're gone
but their words survive claypool's
legacy is made famous because he was
married to the woman known for designing
the first american flag
even though historians debate that today
there is no direct evidence of that
but what we do know about her is that
she made lots of flags which meant
a pretty specialized artisan so she was
a businesswoman
she was an entrepreneur she was a mother
she was an exceptional woman she
really represents the many many
little-known stories
of the revolutionary era a story being
told at what feels like the perfect time
would you describe this as life-changing
it's for me
it's about honoring my mom she had such
a strong love for her family and her
family's history
and having lost her last july
for me the year has been more about
honoring
her and i just i guess i would say i'm
filled with excitement to share the
diary with
people who come and have a love of
history here
because i am a firm believer that
history always repeats itself
and if you learn from it maybe you make
better decisions going forward
for cbs this morning saturday jericho
duncan
philadelphia don't throw out what's in
the shoebox in the garage
sorry i had to say i unfortunately have
done it many times but it's so good to
know that they
they they sifted through it and found a
treasure yeah
we all can share very cool you got a
great background there dana by the way
can you
take that tight shot look at that very
patriotic very patriotic beautiful what
an american girl